now many young people here in germany
say they're disappointed with the
results of the election they say they
feel ignored
if it had been up to first time in young
voters to decide on the new government
the greens would have ended up as the
strongest party the market friendly fdp
would have taken second place with 21
the ultimate winner of the election the
spd would only have received 15
of the vote and the conservative blocked
the cdu
a mere 10 that's a result of polling of
course the left party and the left-wing
afd received the smallest percentage of
the youth vote now dw reporter axel
robot went to meet some young voters in
the eastern german city of leipzig to
get a sense of what they think about
their nation's political leaders
it's the end of term
18 year old oscar sets his high school
diploma next year
like nearly 3 million other first-time
voters he was able to take part in
germany's elections
oscar is interested in politics
he's not a party member but he's active
in his local youth parliament
he's hoping for a centrist
conservative-led government
in coalition with the liberal fdp
and the greens
i found the election a bit dull
i hope that we get a stable government
not like in italy where there's a new
leader every few months we need
stability
oscar's friend tanya also voted for the
first time
i'm tanya vana i thought the election
was shocking and surprising
i'd like a filter coffee to take away
and i'll have a caller
tanya was shocked that the far-right
alternative for germany emerged as the
strongest party in two of the 16 federal
states including here in saxony she
wanted to see a left-led alliance of the
spd greens and the left party but they
didn't get enough votes
it's not at all clear what kind of
coalition government we're going to get
it's doubtful whether it's going to be
as progressive as we are hoping
and that's a bit disheartening
i'm not so worried about the actual
lineup with the strong fdp and greens
and a relatively weak cdu and spd
it should mean the policies of the
smaller coalition partners move up the
agenda
of course there are going to be huge
discussions with either the cdu or the
sbd on which policies make it into the
coalition agreement
and where there will have to be
compromises
whatever happens i think it's going to
be a really exciting government
if only young voters like tanya and
oscar had taken part in the election the
result would have been very different
big gains for the greens and liberals
with the spd and conservatives sidelined
the environment comes first and we need
a proper plan not just talk okay there's
a target to stop burning coal by 2030.
that's true but you also need a plan for
what to replace it with
a big question for me is what pensions
will be like in 30 to 40 years time
and how that will work
that was an important factor in how i
voted
it's all changed after 16 years of
merkel
first we've got to get through the next
four years without her
and that could be tricky
these young voters have only known
germany under angela merkel
when she started as chancellor they were
just
well joining us for more now is tobias
bachala he's a freshly elected member of
the green party in the german parliament
uh mr bakla thanks for being with us
this morning uh you like many people who
voted for your party in the market
friendly fdp you're under 30. so first
of all tell us what do you think this
election result means for young people
including first-time voters in germany
yeah good morning mr martin i think it's
an interesting result because it shows
that for a young generation more than
ever and more than regarding with the
whole population
they asked for a whole new approach
within politics i believe that the idea
of simply managing crisis when they
already appeared
is something that we've seen within the
last years and i believe that's
something which needs to end um of
course as a green i'm talking about like
the climate crisis is something we can't
manage when it already is happening we
need
to prepare for it before it's actually
there but i think in germany we've seen
that with many little things with many
little crisis uh where the big coalition
of the two old big parties um yeah was
mainly stuck with waiting until a
problem actually occurred um instead of
yeah trying to prevent crisis and um i
think that the young generation is
wishing more than others for that to end
when you're out campaigning for this
election talking to people
what did you hear what did young people
in particularly tell you were their main
concerns
i mean digitalization is a big topic in
germany and for the young people i mean
we have been within the corona crisis
struggling with digital policies but
mainly um like with digital
infrastructure in the schools and i
believe that changed the view for many
young people and showed us that we are
actually quite behind when it comes to
digital infrastructure and
this is a big big topic and it occurred
within the corona crisis in nutshell
but of course also the climate crisis i
mean we have people striking on friday
and it has been over half a million
people and again once again a lot of
young people have been there um so i
think those were two big issues pushing
forward and i think that also shows in
the result with strong greens and strong
liberals who
set um digitization on the agenda i mean
we did that as well but um the liberals
pushed it probably it within the
campaign a bit more so i think
this is uh something that shows a lot
to
a freshly elected member of the german
parliament for the green party thank you
very much for talking with us
thanks a lot